all right let's hear from a few more
people we take calls via discord on the
friday show davidpakman.com slash
discord it's completely free completely
free
let's go to uh oh i don't know let's go
to brody from dallas brody what's going
on hey david i hope you're doing well um
i actually have a bone to pick with you
i have to say all right
when you when you call in you do these
beautiful calls sometimes sort of
esoteric topics but you're respectful
and you're kind and all these things but
then it seems like you're plaguing our
discord and subreddit with kind of
strange attacks on me and on the show is
that are there two brodies so to speak
i don't think there are two brodies i
think the latest thing that might have
plagued your reddit was uh the
show about the show
what was that
that was the david pakman show show oh
my god
show about the show that encourages
people to subscribe well that sounds
good i don't know
yeah every show we talk about the
benefits of membership and making sure
that they support your show
hard to be against that well what's on
your mind today brody
um i was actually thinking about um a
interview i heard um with ezra klein a
while back talking about if we are
entering an era of post-persuasion
politics
meaning that um so many people seem to
be subject to asymmetrical polarization
or a stronger level of polarization
and
i wanted to know in your observation
because you've been in the game for a
long time
do you see the era of
politics that we are in now in terms of
retail politics
electoral politics do you see us moving
or are we already in an area where it's
all about registering cultivating and
turning out a base or do you see that
there is still room for persuasion
uh on a broader level i think it's
mostly the former and there is some of
the latter i mean i think you're
starting to get these smaller and
smaller you you know one of the genius
things that trump did and i'm not even
saying that he did it on purpose it just
happened is that he reached people
who had not been paying attention to
politics in any real way so they didn't
even realize that they were being lied
to that trump's campaign promises were
impossible that they were being
propagandized and on and on and on so
what was genius about it was they
completely uncritically were just like
oh trump oh yeah i'm voting for trump
and they were insulated from any kind of
critical thought and that's why when the
access hollywood tape came out it didn't
make a difference in all these different
things
increasingly
to win
you have to find those groups of people
that have not yet become asymmetrically
rattle radicalized the way that you're
pointing out or just asymmetrically
sort of devoted to one side or the other
and trump trump was able to do that so i
think that it's a and it's an important
observation and it's an accurate one
and just as a quick follow-up to that do
you think that the current
infrastructure and the current messaging
that the broader democratic party and
candidates have
is capable of fulfilling the uh
the mission there i guess that you
outlined in terms of being able to find
folks that are able to be persuaded and
create a media ecosystem that promotes
that hasn't i mean not so far so far
they've failed on two fronts one they've
failed to properly fund the effort to
create that ecosystem and number two
they've failed to identify a contingent
of the half of the country that doesn't
vote that could be
sort of assembled as a voting block and
activated so so far they've not proven
they can do it
awesome well i appreciate you taking my
call and i will try and behave a little
bit better in your discord yeah let's
keep it clean on there please
yes sir okay
brody from dallas great to hear from him